from timcast.com America shares strong
alliance with North Korea VP Harris says
White House plays damage control the
White House appears to have removed
Harris's mention of North Korea in an
official transcript Harris mistakenly
made the claim during her first trip to
the demilitarized zone separating North
and South Korea this week let's play the
video here for you guys so the United
States
very important relationship which is an
alliance with the Republic of North
Korea
and
it is an alliance that is strong and
enduring
how did somebody goes now now here's why
this is important right we I mentioned
we brush on this but I got to bring it
up because the deeper issue here is
I've often ragged on Joe Biden for
saying Libya when he meant Syria and the
danger of misspeaking is to public
capacity yeah
people around the world who just heard
this and I wonder what impact that will
have on a lot of things because think
about it this way what if kamalaris
actually were to come out and say we are
proud to say that we have a strong
alliance with North Korea and she meant
it like Kim Jong-un comes here and he's
like I want to do a deal and open up
trade and and work with you guys let me
know what to do and it was a tremendous
historic moment the problem is when she
said this everyone immediately went she
sang the wrong word she met South Korea
and the scary thing is we cannot trust
in what they're saying I think it's
going to have a major impact on
economics on war and conflict peace
treaties it could except that she's the
vice president but what I see in this is
if CNN would have been doing covered the
same instance and it were Donald Trump
or even Mike Pence they wouldn't have
used the word mistakenly right you know
what I mean that's what that's what hits
me and I see this it's really bad in
local media they would say he lied yeah
they would say he lied in the lines of
North Korea or that he wants an alliance
with North Korea and he's going to do it
tomorrow that's that's the difference I
see here at least at least they had the
Integrity to say hey she mistakenly said
this but hey it's kind of funny we we
should maybe ask her about it and clear
it up you know yeah I think it's amazing
uh I'm wondering if we have the uh well
it was removed from the transcript I
thought that was actually really
hilarious because what I saw was like a
strikethrough like them just being like
whoopsie we didn't mean to say that
think about this what this what this
would mean though if Kamala Harris is
going to meet with someone in private
and she says something like this and
then are they supposed to assume that
when she has a word she's wrong
well they do it with Joe Biden all the
time this is the thing though how old is
Kamala Harris he's in her 40s or what
50s
she's in her 50s right yeah early 50s
early 50s and she is also sundowning
yeah she's having the same cognitive
decline well and why is she wearing
something they're eating like what if
you know I feel really bad about this
like what if Biden actually was really
sharp but Putin was putting poison
slowly in their food and so like we're
sitting here laughing at him and mocking
them and they're really just slowly
being wasted Away by yeah someone say
polonium or something well she's 50
50.50s yeah she's 57 okay 58 October
20th yeah you know so uh I don't know if
impeaching or 25th amendment ding Joe
Biden's Gonna Save Us guys I but I also
think you know she wasn't that bright to
begin with yeah so so yeah the effects
are evident earlier in life if you
weren't that bright she's not known for
you know yeah she's not a good public
speaker she was is she losing her she's
smart like does she have like a high IQ
but I can make them puns there but I'm
not because she's she's worked her way
on mature adults yeah well she's worked
her way that's one way to say it
you know one-handed mayor Willie Brown
working she did I think that brilliant
reference did a lot of work work
Brilliance is communicative and so is
stupidity and and having a a president
that's if you act like that's normal
what Joe Biden's acting like then then
people are going to start acting like
that because they think it's normal
remember the kids will be like oh that's
how I'm supposed to be remember Freedom
oh goodness another complete fabrication
I know another complete fabrication
yeah this is what politicians do lie
some of them are not good liars she is
not a good liar she's not witty she's
not fast with it she can't play with it
but if Joe Biden's taking a nap and
we're being bombed she's gonna go in the
War Room North Korea
that's that's the type of people in
charge right no it's theater if I was
ever in politics I would either be
brutally honest or just absurdly deceit
deceptive to the point where it's
obvious so it's just like lie in the
most outrageous ways just so you can be
like you you know politician's a liar
right yes that's probably one way to do
it because if you go and try to be
honest they'll accuse you of lying
you'll say something like look we've got
a huge problem right now with this
pipeline what they're doing is I said
otherwise they're like ah you're falling
at your line I just feel like aliens
oh yeah a UFO was right overhead we all
saw it and they'd be like whoa they're
admitting it now their brain no this is
the crazy thing right if you say
something about Ray just people go they
admitted it yeah but if you say
something seemingly normal they're like
nah you got to be lying I expect an
outrageous story explaining what's
really going on what is it what is it
that is breaking our brains to that end
you know what I mean yeah our brains
well not our brains but you know
Collective the world especially the
United States it seems that what you're
describing there is is so endemic in in
our society that we can't believe a
blatant truth we poison we can't believe
it high fructose in 92 we started
poisoning and then those people had kids
so it's like the second generation of
poison idiocracy this year is basically
we're looking at something like that
it's terrifying phthalates and it's
plastics it's high fructose it's
probably radiation vegetable seed oils
this is a glass bottle right here we
have we do have plastic water bottles
here but I get a lot of glass bottles
and then we also have refillable glass
bottles too because we have purified
well water with added minerals yeah I
think it's the Plastics computer
monitors that's all that radiation
staring at a monitor or even just the
Adderall and and all the stuff
pharmaceutical company right the
companies there's five insurance
agencies running the global medical
industry right now what PCB is poly
chloride biphenols is that what it
stands for yeah I know it's biphenol I
think the couple generations of that in
our bloodstreams is screwing with our
brain yeah it's the generational effect
so like the parents are all messed up
from it and the Obesity but then they
have kids who immediately start using it
when they're little and before that it
was lead and it was lead I mean that
lowered IQ yeah
fluoride yeah I mean it's time to go
live in the woods and just live off of
purified and you know get your own
charcoal carbs out of your diet for 10
days I mean you'll feel like you're
you're burning inside for about on day
five on but after day 10 it's out of you
and you quite clear and then if you
start eating bread again it's so easy to
kick it once that didn't happen to me
when I when I cut the carbs out really I
didn't notice anything I had a horrible
pain you lost weight throbbing I mean I
lost a lot of weight really fast but I
wasn't I wasn't I think the turtle flu I
wasn't no headaches it's just normal in
fact within a few days I just instantly
felt better I also cut the sugar out I
did it in one in a 10-day period because
I Was preparing for an Ayahuasca fast
and they have a specific diet so like no
low salt no sugar no carb and I was like
day five I was on my body was on fire
but I just toughed through it and by day
10 I felt phenomenal I think Kamala and
Joe need to go on like an Ayahuasca
guided trip
just head out to Delaware you know and
just do a little Mega dose of mushrooms
what am I doing
yeah see North Korea or if they want to
fight a war bring them on a retreat
right be like hey you're going to do
high doses of mushrooms acid the LSD DMT
whatever you have to do one of those
afterwards if you still want to fight
each other and you want a war you guys
got to fight it yourselves sorry duel it
out figure it out yourselves man on man
uh one one on woman doesn't matter why
don't do it why don't we do that what
movie was it um was it uh Troy where
it's like yeah instead of going to war
that's your best fighters will fight and
then absolutely and that future can
happen if we didn't put all of our faith
in government but nobody can happen
unless you nominate a champion and then
it's like I hope you win because I don't
want to live by their rules like oh we
lost but oh well no fighting I like that
you're encouraging me not to put my
faith in government because I think
directly appealing to the Russian people
is the way to go you're listening right
now and I hear you and I'm with you
people you're in Russia you citizens are
listening right now I know it and we got
your back man none of us want this war
as a Russian guy he's like they're
talking about the moon
we're on Earth together right now in
this moment you're listening yeah yes
Vlad you don't have to comply Vlad it's
okay is that like the most common name
in Russia or something pretty much yeah
it can also be like this Muhammad you're
already watching the show but I'm done
appealing to the the politicians for
this solution it's the people it's
bottom up man we got to work together I
got it Dave you forgot to take the
garbage out
Dave is very happy that you mentioned
that right now his wife will also be
very happy don't forget your anniversary
Eric you're pleasing a lot of people
tonight I'm already at Super chats and
people are going to be alive whoa and
your view is just Skyrocket all the
Eric's and all the devs all the
muhammads and vlads come together and
World War and kamalas yeah man it feels
like
the the issue I think with this war
stuff
someone super chatted something like
this that the liberal International
economy needs to be stopped and that's
what Russia is doing but I think that's
just propaganda still I don't think I
don't think Vladimir Putin is some noble
guy who's like no the New World Order is
bad and Must Be Stopped I'm the yeah
right he's got his own interests he's
got his own agenda he's got his own
ideology you've got competing ideologies
I'll tell you this though I don't like
the world economic Forum people and
Davos group they're crackpots and
they're psychotic so I don't want to
root for anybody other than hey we
shouldn't go to war we should mind our
own business and we we really should not
go to war because we could find
ourselves in a Goblin King state where
people are vying for power and just
killing each other trying to take the
throne over and over and over and over
and again not want to live in that realm
everyone always says you know what would
happen if there was no government people
say Warlords would take over what are we
living through right now well like
Warlords have taken over they're taking
over and they're pushing for war but
most of the earth is not an in Conflict
right now you know I mean we're sitting
right here having a conversation so I
mean there's at least some structure
that give us now where where are we
heading that direction it seems that way
it sure does seem that but but the
possibilities of Calamity and the
destruction of the entire world is there
because of the technological
advancements because of the military
hardware that is out there that could
literally wipe this entire planet off of
the out of the universe so that that you
know but we've been living with that
since 1940 yeah
it would be like chaotic like right now
there's the technological advancements
in nuclear weapons well I know I know
it's gotten I know but I'm just saying
we've been and they've been pushing it
right along but we've been living with
that and better angels have prevailed up
to this point but it seems like we have
the all of these forces just pushing us
more and more and multiple different
levels into more and more conflict
because you were talking about if we had
a World War III I'm I'm really concerned
like you were saying that we would that
America wouldn't be unified like they
were at 9 11 or we were in 1945 or at
the beginning of the Vietnam War even we
would have our own own sub Civil Wars
while this other war was going on
someone in the comment section told me
to go to mogundishu I did I went to
Mogadishu Somalia just to talk about
this very specific issue because
everyone says you don't like government
go to Somalia I did I found nothing but
governments everywhere there's like four
governments and four governments
literally sending weapons and arms
everywhere the Middle Eastern government
at the Turkish uh the United States this
is a bit we gotta do for cast castle
where it's like Luke's nightmare is ever
he like turns the corner and there's
like the people from the government ah
he turns around as a different
government government inspectors
licensing
but we are chained Somalia you could see
my adventures in Mogadishu uh and and
you could see uh you know all the
government that's there I can solve all
of the political violence in this
country simmer everything down it really
is easy government mandated chicken
ownership amen everybody's got to take
care of chickens and and you eat the
eggs no more buying Farm egg sorry Farm
businesses all your egg businesses are
gone because we're gonna have our own
chickens and what we're going to learn
from this is peace
yes right no no if if we really had a
caring and considerate government during
these these very difficult times during
these very hard financial times they
would be trying to incentivize personal
responsibility they would try to say hey
maybe you should get a chicken maybe you
should try to learn how to grow your own
food maybe you should try to have some
kind of livestock so you could actually
not be dependent on anyone because we're
not going to be there for you when we
screw you over that's it real quick but
I just want to point out you're you're
right on that one being personally the
point I'm really trying to make is
owning chickens what I really mean to
say is be responsible for the food you
eat source as much of your own life as
you can but I just want to add there is
nothing more heartwarming than walking
up to the coop and watching all of the
chickens waddle over to you because they
know you got food and it's hilarious it
is they're like goofy looking little
things with their jaws hanging their
mouths hanging open like morons but we
have active attacks on people who try to
teach individual responsibility yeah you
know I mean just look at Jordan Peterson
I think you all were talking about this
a little bit yesterday but it's like
they attack him for no other reason and
he's just trying to help people be
self-sufficient and then they and that's
what teachers in schools used to teach
is teach kids how to be self-sufficient
here's a really interesting story I
think man but in I I found a
kindergartner test from uh from like
1983 and in order to be first of all you
were six almost seven years old to go
into kindergarten back then and when one
of the line items on the test was you
have to be able to walk six blocks away
from your home go into the store buy
something and bring the money back with
correct change to your parents that was
something that you had to be able to do
to go into school now they want you you
know at three years old and this is what
I keep telling people at home in
Oklahoma because you know we're all gun
owners and I believe in Second Amendment
but the government is after your kids
and you they don't need your guns if
they have your children yeah they don't
need your guns if you look at what's
happened in our society the people who
are being attacked the most are the
people who have the most Freedom who has
the most Freedom Farmers people who are
personally responsible for themselves
people who are living in the middle of
nowhere and don't need anyone or
anything they are the number one targets
the number one attack of our current
establishment and I think that's being
done for a reason thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there